all right R number
eight so again make sure you it always
happens in cha Sensei forms is everyone
starts getting into personal weapon
range and you part of weapons is that
you don't open yourself up to the
personal weapons okay so you you have to
be out of range so so metrics here go uh
one again we know he's not touching me
on
that
two I'm here I want to be at the tip of
his weapon because that's where it's
light on three
only only what I need to cut him don't
over penetrate you can see I'm now in
Striking range so only what I need okay
he goes boom and I move back out again
not sideways where we're in here again
too close Okay I mooved back out and
again say only what I need keep your
hand there please only what I need only
for The Cutting portion they hit don't
over
penetrate he goes on only what he needs
that's it all only what he needs is the
hands go back so the you can me on this
one this is the beginning of move eight
so as he goes up I go with it and I'm
now on the other side of the weapon if I
don't go with it he'll hit my hands okay
so go back as he goes around with makos
I'm on the other side of the weapon he
misses entirely okay then my sword is in
the right place he's going to hit my
root cage here so I do AO ten con and
I've cut the hand off again okay again
deep banging the stage here we go slow
bo
this
[Applause]
must
[Music]
CL
don't be
[Music]
afraid
[Applause]
[Music]
detail on number eight okay so I'm going
to get
there um you you don't you cannot edem
me you cannot edem me 10 again he's got
one move okay he's got one step I can
only get one step but if you pay
attention when I did the preceding move
I would have had to have done
sugii and my sugii should be oriented to
where his body is and since he's trying
to flank me my Tashi the second half I
should have moved to orient myself
towards him because I'm fighting the
Archer not the arrow and that is all the
angle deviation you need to make a true
Ido tenom work okay so let me explain
this as we're going nice and slow
boom H okay so I do do you see how he's
moving because we're going to be dynamic
and he's going to be moving to do his
angle deviation okay right so his angle
deviation is makos there it is right
there come back and so as I see him move
and I do my cut go back as I Tashi and I
see him move after I stepped up here
okay cuz now I'm oriented on him if I
didn't step up here the flank would just
be too huge it's way too huge okay you
should stay oriented to him as he moves
so now when he does the ski it is
just uh should T go back rewind the film
I don't need to take another one you
won't be able to do it going to be too
fast
okay okay okay move nine is just an
angle deviation but you're going to
follow the same principle of keep
yourself oriented to the Archer don't
fight the arrow that means don't uh let
him flank you don't let his person flank
you and don't think you're not being
flank just because you're touching his
weapon okay so as we go on we'll go slow
[Music]
bo bo bo I move this way because stay
there because to stay here he's he's got
the angle on me so I have to orient
myself
okay
come around we'll finish this move 10 in
St into toi
boom so here we got move nine and 10
we'll just do them
together around
boom don't run away from the
weapon
let it touch you it's not going to kill
you I want you to do the
fall
oh
all
right all right move 11 but a small
review again the what I am trying to do
is dealing with the Tactical fact that
he has a longer weapon so a lot of what
I'm doing is defanging the snake uh
until the very end now uh again as I
mentioned at the beginning chibba
sensei's forms were constantly evolving
and some of us learned like that the
Toshi Zuki was the last move and then we
all knew another set I don't know if it
ever had a name we have videos of it um
theka is is in there too okay so uh I
like that I'll stick the suat in there
because it's more of a conclusion I
think uh and the form should have some
sort of conclusion to it and here's why
I think it's a conclusion and the uh
atoshi Zuki is not the atoshi Zuki is
the same type of strategy that the Joe's
been using from the beginning which is
hit the hands pin the guy and ski okay
uh well I don't there it doesn't make
any sense that all of a sudden it worked
you see it doesn't make sense that that
would be the ending so Suka at uh is
more of an ending that makes sense to me
uh because what it does is the guy made
the mistake by leaving underneath open
and a person that has shorter range
weapons whether they're personal weapons
or artifactual weapons they now have the
opportunity to close and use that
shorter range weapon and that ends the
the whole thing that they're trying to
do there's no EXT to rotate or anything
like that okay so we'll do that as our
last move our 11th move okay so
again everything is
fine walk
boom around here is where I keep this a
now okay here's the ax the rotating
cross and as he's trying to do that ski
I have the lighter end the lighter end I
was using on the first move to drop this
time on the lighter end I'm using it to
keep it up and I enter when he's
entering with my
own strike to the
sternum make sure when you do it you
don't grab your normal cutting grip you
have to leave about an inch minimum on
the end of his 2 the weapon is hitting
him
[Music]
for
all right all right so uh we're not
going to break down um the Kessa or the
um OSI Zuki or theuk because we have
lots of videos on that and I think the
overall strategy the stickiness all the
the things that we mentioned uh leading
up to these moves you can see that
they're exactly the same okay so we'll
stop there that's our intro into soncho
31 and then we will continue to refine
it and what we're looking for in our
refinement is that our circles the
rotating spiral rotating crosses are
extremely tiny they're very tiny on both
sides okay and so as my people get
better at this form you're going to see
uh you'll see this version in it but
you'll also Go whoo it looks totally
different now um that's our goal here
all right thank you